voilà à cet échange dans quelques
instants avant cela je me tourne vers
vous armer charrier bonjour armelle
bonjour il ya les informations qui nous
parviennent à un moment où l'on se parle
le gouverneur de la région de chiang
yves est en train d'assurer de déclarer
que sa région a été bombardée toute la
nuit malgré les promesses russes la
présidence ukrainienne qui indique
également et qui confirme les craintes
américaines formulées ces dernières
heures les troupes russes sont en train
d'être redéployée sur sur l'est en train
d'encercler les les forces du craignent
end ans dans cette région d'où ce
scepticisme affiché on l'entend très
clairement ici et là même si on a envie
de rester positif est ce que on est en
mesure de croire les russes aujourd'hui
en tout cas pour le moment il n'y a
aucune preuve concrète oui en fait ce qu
ont communiqué les russes finalement
c'est que leurs buts de guerre a changé
et que ils n'ont plus la volonté d'aller
s'emparer de kiev s'ils n'ont eu à un
moment donné peut-être qu'ils auront de
nouveau demain on est en train de parler
juste au moment précis et que donc du
coup ce qu'ils veulent eux c'est arrivé
à prendre l'est du pays est arrivé à le
prendre dans une j'allais dire vision
plus large que juste ce qu'on avait vu
des républiques séparatistes qu'on avait
pour le moment c'est à dire qu'ils
veulent en fait tout ce qui est la
région de lougansk de donetsk et ils
veulent le port de marioupol parce
qu'ils veulent l'arrêt la mer d'azov et
donc pour cela ils ont besoin maintenant
de rappeler leurs hommes et de mettre
des troupes fraîches des troupes plus
combattante dans ce lieu dans ce coin là
en quelque sorte donc ce qui était en
train de combattre du côté de kiev a
priori sont rappelés ça permet comme ça
en fait de reprendre les séparatistes
ukrainien fallait la résistance
ukrainienne à revers et donc de faire
une poche d'encerclement derrière c'est
en fait ce qui se dessinait sur le
terrain ils ont vu qu'ils avaient des
endroits où ils n'arrivaient pas à
percer alors on n'est pas sur le fait
qu'ils vont quitter kiev fondée sur le
fait qu'ils vont se déplacer légèrement
et évidemment la question de marioupol
centrale pour eux parce qu'à partir du
moment donné où ils ont marioupol non
seulement ils ont un port mais en plus
leur libère
des moyens d'action offensif pour
ensuite remonter vers vers le personnel
c'est république a c'est vrai que depuis
le début de cette sale guerre un peu
plus d'un mois on a vu les deux camps
changé de ton la rhétorique a aussi
beaucoup évolué et un côté ukrainien
comme côté russe côté ukrainien quand
même le président volodymyr zelensky à
s'est dit pris un certain nombre de
concessions oui il a trouvé le tempo en
fait c'est à dire qu'à un moment donné
pour l'instant ces hommes font du
travail correct sur le terrain et donc
il ya des défaites vis-à-vis des russes
donc c'est le moment pour les ukrainiens
d'aller enclencher une discussion avec
eux est de dire on est capable
d'entendre grand temps que vous ne
voulez pas le temps donc c'est bien ce
qu'il dit je suis capable de retenir ça
il est capable de dire on sait qu' il ya
des régions qui sont allés devant disons
le pro russe où la crimée qui est quand
même maintenant à l'excès par les russes
qu'il aura du mal à reconquérir donc il
est capable de dire on peut en parler
ensuite sachant que évidemment ça
prendra des années pour nom de mener des
pourparlers sur ces territoires là à
condition de sauver le reste à condition
de sauver sa capitale à condition de
sauver une ukraine qui ne soit pas trop
dépenser là où on voit que les rues sont
quand même en train d'entendre ce qu'ils
disent ok on veut bien les discuter avec
le président ukrainien c'est la première
fois que poutine reconnaît qu'il peut
elle négocier avec zelensky qu'il ne
nomme pas mais jusqu'à présent il ne lui
faisait pas confiance il ne voulait même
pas en entendre parler il voulait même
pas satan ça tu allais à la même table
avec lui mais on est encore dans la
guerre c'est à dire qu'on est encore sur
ce qui se passe sur le terrain qui va
dicter en fait si la capacité derrière
de faire un cessez le feu et émergentes
mais en témoignait merci beaucoup